you're surrounded by some good-looking
ladies here tonight sir can I tell you I
think that we are all still talking
about your Golden Globes yes there
wasn't a dry eye in the house there
wasn't a dry eye people watching Rita to
here I mean everybody I saw was my
girlfriend in my babies my girlfriend
was a lady who delivered some of those
babies so it was like a moment
transported by time and it was a little
woozy on top of that where were you guys
when you heard the news about the Oscar
nomination
we were we were away and I got up and I
got attached to saying congratulations
oh yeah yeah the phone just exploded and
we had sort of I had gone to bed forgot
forgetting that the next day was the
nomination so it was really it was a
great way a great day don't start the
more great way to start the morning now
at your table you came in came into the
kitchen said honey I think even mine was
going off as well do you realize this is
the 40th anniversary of your acting
debut
do you remember what movie that was ok
it 40th that would have been 79 he knows
your role that made me 800 bucks
I was able to pay off the loans that I
had taken to join the Screen Actors
Guild and we shot four we shot for two
days on Staten Island my favorite things
from Golden Globes was callin saying you
know what it's like nice to see my dad
lose once in a while
what did you make it back I didn't hear
that very funny family though is you
know it keeps you humble you know what I
mean it's good to see my dad not win
everything all the time what was great
was after that he came up as a dad I'm
glad you experienced this disappointment
so early in your career so that you'll
you'll appreciate the good things that
come along later on here you say you
took out loans to get your sag money
director really yeah yeah well listen if
you don't have it you don't have it
there's a type of thing that it was
better if you had it so you could get
the job but you had to get the job in
order to join the it was a good you got
the job then it cost you everything you
earned on that job to join sad because I
didn't have the luxury of my wife's red
carpet arrival into the Screen Actors
Guild because I got I got my Screen
Actors Guild card because I did an
episode of The Brady Bunch tell me one -
who are you that there's three four
tells me who's gonna score I was
watching on a Friday night at Matt goads
house this episode of The Brady Bunch
where this cheerleader was so cute she
knocked me out love that more than my
bit zone and good thing you did because
you look like a dream tonight whoo you
sure do ma'am this is Roland amore and
the diamonds they're good Kathy Waterman
can we play a little fashion-forward
with you all right first things first
what's the essential that you always
have to have in your clutch when you
come to what's in there besides your
phone there whiskey besides you're a
little flask is always good oh let's see
we always have to have an extra pair of
contact lenses smart lady yes smart that
gets in your eye or you cry and that
tissue gets in there and then you have
to take out your lens so an extra set of
contact lenses
we love you guys what a bleb my opinion
guys have had
[Music]